welcome back to las vegas now the
liberty project is a local charity
dedicated to rescuing wild mustangs
while also healing and supporting
veterans in our community and joining us
today is the liberty project founder and
former raiders quarterback jay schroeder
jay how are you i'm good thanks for
having me today yeah thanks for coming
back and this is really some incredible
work that you are doing tell us a little
bit about the liberty project well the
liberty projects came out of the heart
of my partner j.p
hoffman lost his best friend due to
suicide and he's a rancher so we just
combined the two working with horses
bringing in veterans and it's been a
beautiful marriage the horses and and
the veterans get along great so it's a
lot of fun yeah we're seeing some
pictures here on our screen it looks so
beautiful out there too where is your
ranch located i love seeing all these
photos believe it or not we're we're
45-50 minutes from right here in the
studio we're just out in sandy valley uh
go down south and head out west and you
come out to this beautiful little valley
out there we're all the way across there
and
it's a beautiful spot tony curtis used
to own the ranch that we bought and it
was set up perfectly for the horses that
we have so
the wild mustangs come in and they get
they're a little wild but it's uh it's
fun uh training them and seeing the the
transformation not only in them but in
the vets that get a chance to handle
them and there's something about horses
right they're just so therapeutic talk
about that bond and especially how that
helps the veterans that are in need of
it well
the thing that we say all the time is a
horse is a mirror to you okay so if
you're upset or if you have something
going on you walk up to one of these
wild mustangs they're going to treat you
the same way yeah and you don't want a
thousand pound 1200 pound animal
treating you that way so you better be
calm you better be loving and that's a
great therapeutic recipe yeah it works
for both actually so both of them are
helping each other without them knowing
it yeah it's a really special bond that
forms i'm sure and you couldn't do all
of these things without the support of
the community i'm sure let's talk about
this upcoming golf tournament you're
hosting yeah we have a charity golf
tournament at revere in
in henderson coming up june 10th all the
information is on our website you can go
to
betsandhorses.org everything is on there
love to have everybody come out and play
golf enjoy the day and support a great
cause it does take a lot
to help the vets we do more than just
the econ therapy we do brain paint would
help us with ptsd and we have to pay you
know technicians and different things
like that so the costs got up very
quickly and just really quickly if
someone is watching let's say there's a
veteran out there who is in need of your
services what's the best way for them to
get in contact with you same thing
through the website everything is on the
website you can get in contact everybody
will get back with you
as soon as we possibly can to get you
out and get you evaluated
and try to help you out we you know
we'll do our best to help everybody we
don't have all the answers but we'll try
to find the correct answer for them well
jay thank you so much for everything
you're doing in our community and any
way that we can help support you we're
always happy to do that so thank you so
much all the information will be on your
screen here for that golf tournament
friday june 10th at revere golf club in
henderson 7 a.m tea time thank you jay